للوهله الاولى تخالو ان الحديث يدور عن
معاناه يوسف مع النزوح لكن الامراه اكبر
من ذلك
يوسف ابن العشر سنوات يعيش بساق واحده بعد
ان فقد الاخرى بقصف طائرات النظام لبيت
اسرته في حلب الشمالي
يشق طريقه الى المدرسه مستندا الى عكازه
يطمح اسوه باقرانه الى التعلم
[موسيقى]
يعني يوسف من الطلاب
الالكترونات وكانت هذه المشكله سبب انه
يتعثر تعليمه او انه ما يتابعوا التعليم
ولكن يوسف ما شاء الله استطاع انه يتقلب
على هذا الحاجز ويجاوزه وانسجن
[موسيقى]
حياته التعليميه ان شاء الله اللي راح
ينجح فيها يوسف
الحرب خلفت الكثير من الماسي كحالي عبد
الله الذي حدثنا عن مراره معيشته بهذا
الحال
بلغت نسبه العجز في قطاع التعليم
اكثر من مليون طفل يعيشون في المخيمات
وتجاوزت نسبه الاميه خمسين في المئه في ما
يقدر عدد المتسربين من المدارس بقرابه 37
الفطالب وجدنا انه سبب ضعف الوضع المادي
بالنسبه للاسر هو يتدخل بشكل رئيسي
فانشاهد عمله الطلاب من خلال دراسنا
للمراه داخل وجدنا نسب الاكبر في المخيمات
فا نحن من خلال جهدنا قدرنا نعيد بعض
الطلاب للمدارس ولكن احنا بندخل فقره اخرى
هي البيئه الصحيه للمدارس فنشاهد الى الان
تنتشر بعض مدارس فيها الخيم او الغرف في
المعدنيه التي صعب فيها التدريس صيفا
والشتاء
ولم تكن النواحي المعيشيه الاخرى للاطفال
احسن حالا بسبب تاثير الفقر فيهم حيث بلغت
نسبه العائلات الواقعه تحت خط الفقر اكثر
من 85% ونسبه العائلات التي وصلت الى حد
الجوع قرابه الاربعين في المئه يقول
القائمون على شؤون التعليميه ان رعايه
تعليم الاطفال ليست بالمستوى المطلوب كما
ان التسرب المدرسيه مستمر ونتيجه زياده في
نسب الاميه التي تعمق معاناتهم كنازحين
عمر الحوراني الجزيره ريف حلب